今日も空気が
おいしいな
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょ―です
今回の動画はこちら！
キャッチできた
再びこちらメガバルーンでございます
このメガバルーン、前回も使ったんですけども、どんなものかと言いますと、
よしキタ
できたぁー！
できました！
こちらがメガバルーンです
投げてみましょう
という感じで、めっちゃ飛びます
こちらのメガバルーンめちゃくちゃ飛ぶんですけども
今回は
こちらに60個のメガバルーンを準備しました
僕は思ったわけですよ
メガバルーン1つで30メートル飛ぶということは
60個のメガバルーンをこう、くっつけて投げると
いや、いきますよ
いやホントわかんないから、世の中何起きるかわかりませんから
メガバルーンを信じて
メガバルーン60個作って、それをひとくくりにまとめて
僕がぶん投げます
そうすると、何メートル飛ぶのか
今回はちょっと検証してみようと思います
作るのが、めんどくさいでございます
ではいこう！
腹やべぇ
おっけーー！！
完成しました
60個膨らませました
無事、メガバルーンを60個膨らますことができました
2時間かかりました
というわけで、ここからなんですけども
このメガバルーン60個を1つにまとめます
セロハンテープで軽く、くっつけて
なんとかうまい具合に60個を1つのメガバルーンにしてみようと思います
高さ的にいい感じじゃない？
やばいな、ちょっとまずいな、やばいどうしよう
ちょっとうまく くっつかなくて
どうしよう
で、ちょっと見てのとおりセロハンテープだとくっつかなかったので
ちょっと、僕がこれからセロハンテープ買いに行ってきます
まさき後は頼んだ
オッケー
あーねぇ、急ぎだから！💢
とったど・・・
ガムテープ買ってきました
ちょっとホントに時間が無いので
早めにもう全部固めちゃいます
真ん中をいこう
よっぽどのことが無い限り大丈夫だと思う
オッケー！完成！！
はい、というわけでようやく完成しましたこちら
メガバルーン60個の合体型
作るのに約3時間かかったが
もうね、この際もう
飛ばなくてもいい。
俺はこの3時間全力をかけてこれを作った
まさきとがんばってメガバルーンを60個膨らました
それだけでも、俺たちは1800メートル飛んでんだよ
早速、飛ばしてみようと思います
マジで1800メートル飛ばすから
どうだ！
はっはっはー
いきます！
はい！
いきます
うおぉぉおおお！！
わあぁぁぁぁああ